Richi Z is worth 700 million quid David
Cameron made 10 million quid within a
year of leaving office Tony Blair is
worth like a 100 million quid you know I
would like to ask a question to to the
British people and the people of the
world watching this right if the people
whose job it is to protect you and to
protect the economy are definitely not
going to protect the economy whose job
is it to protect the economy because I
know people out there will be thinking
look I'm just an ordinary guy I'm
struggling to get by this is not my job
I'm sorry the fire brigade is not coming
the job the people whose job is to fix
this I'm sorry but they're not going to
fix this and I know you have your gripes
with labor and maybe we'll get our time
to talk about it they're not going to
fix it